Dam Racing Fort Harris got their first and
it comes to Center ice and Conor derer kayin
Addison nice rookie season last year 29 Points
that drive rebound off the post and aror Jacky
took it away out of the blue paint just in time
in a cap challenged team that I will get into in
a little bit good Felino in all alone he dances in
rebound up and goodro nearly made it one nothing
in deep there lost the puck new hook free it for
Kaden Gully gly tries to go to some open ice for
Pearson with new hook Pearson in front new hook
handled by Mark Andre flurry he can help this team
Dave in so many ways his veteran leadership goal
scoring and obviously massive in the faceoff dot
is the wild possible two onone the other way
short-handed that R shot score Brandon to the
short hand landed goal and it's the wild striking
first to make it one nothing at the Bell Center P
of the Pucket pops the other way I like the Dame
decision to shoot the puck so often this is a pass
that's forced across he's got Eric's neck with
him instead of taking it Mike Madison plays the
PASS gives Samuel montmo the shot it's not a
great angle the perfect shot inside the post
by Brandon Dame new hook on the bck tried to work
it back and duim intercepts and they're gone again
another two-on one led by duim he'll wait shoots
that stopped Conor derer battling for a rebound
score that second effort and they do it again
another short-handed goal Connor derer makes it
two nothing on a disastrous power play here for
Montreal their first shorty their second one is
on the board and Tanner Pearson actually makes
an excellent back check here watch him Define
he's got D going to the net and he stays with it
it's just a freed up stick two Montreal Canadians
standing there Jacky comes back in the play as
well watch this KCK get fre ice tilted right
now in the Wild's favor 10 shots and two goals
here in this first period another turnover R
shot kicked to side as Rossy nearly catches his
second in the NHL nice little start to his very
young National Hockey League career he's going
to be a very good player with the opportunity
to cover him in the U te and he's always been a
heavy player Rosy across off the post Felino one
of the few guys to Wi a USHL title with Green Bay
and then a Memorial Cup with the London Knights
we talk about trips up he's had a stay of three
games turnover gallager Anderson shot Mark Andre
flurry from their minor league club to
complement their 20 with a salary minimum
of $875,000 so they can bring someone up just a
technical rule but tonight they're skating with
19 but they're skating pretty well with 19
never F the mark Johansson zuk Carell gets
it back zuk Carell below the goal line right
in front Erikson X score the second Jam play
power play goal and Erikson e has made it
a 3 nothing contest back to Capri off it
came out to Eric sck who pounds at home from
in tight it's been a special team show for
the Minnesota Wild and still a minute 44
seconds left on the power play to do more
damage so for Matt zcell he's second all time
nearly provided that spark to havs need in
this game as Carill capriso in Shoots look
out bable lost it follow a try and elate no
goal from the official as monom B was down and
out and in [Applause] favor Rock Faber through
Center Ice brings it into the Zone one time
drive and Pino just missed his Coffield back
on the ice and it's five on five for Montreal
Middleton near Point dishes back in der round
the boards as it's chipped up Patrick Moon
tried to get it to the line back to work
maroon protects the puck right in front good
pass and D nearly had another one zuk Carell
keep as he had kill keisop and caop excuse me
nearly had another chance to free stop shoots
that was knocked down by Tanner Pearson maybe
a two-on one with Monahan Pearson R shot score
his second as a half Tanner Pearson gets the Bell
Center going it's three to [Music] [Applause] one
it his first campaign is a half starts with
a shot block by Tanner Pearson in his own end
on on a capristo shot coming back he's got
Young mermis on defense he's reading a two
onone and an excellent decision to shoot this
Puck so often the pass is forced across Evans
gets taken down far boards but able to get
the pass away Saar space shoots in a right
pad save rebound big drive and what a glove
throws it back Johansson he'll bring it in
himself Johansson for zuk Carell kayen Addison
fakes the shot zuk Carell CPR off score that
dangerous spot far Circle Kil capriso power play
goal and it's 41 wild the Special Teams rocket
tonight for Minnesota they do all right there
showing in fine fashion how they look for each
other he finds that seam across as that seam
opens up kin Addison with the fake shot helps
open the seam up and as kayin Addison throws it
across to zukar 12 seconds left Jacky taken down
by Johansson H still possess the puck aror
Jacky 6 seconds left Sosi quick strike gger
rebound try and the pat of flurry Pearson nearly
had another one but Mark Andre flurry brilliant
to keep it a 4-1 game by Mark Andre flurry
two in a row but watch the left pad on the
rebound from Tanner Pearson right a penalty
for that late hit on Johansson at the end of
the second so the Montreal Canadians will start
the third period short-handed and at last check
Dave no Kaden ghouly to start the third period
on the bench as well so we'll keep you posted
on that so high slot couldn't get the shot away
HS trying to break away anolin it wanted to get
it to Evans and he floats it all the way down
to flurry but Evans on the puck tried to Dish
it to the trailer kovich he's in kovich what a
stop flurry kov sneaking in great pass from Jake
Evans watch the pads go up and over capris
off space in front he wanted the tip from
Johansson Johansson around the boards for zuk
Carell 27 seconds left to the minor penalty
cof in down low ericon X score another Power
Play goal his second of the night it is 5-1
Minnesota his career high and he's showing
sign are going north of that with an early
effort here strong move on the power play
stepping out hard and it's that hard step
out there's no hesitation pass comes from cof
and it's one immediate step and then that stick
just has to get around the right pad of montam
Suzuki Monahan cross ice Coffield shoots oh
blurry Coffield thought he sored one through and
flurry made the Stop and again temper boiling at
the Bell Center here and the late stages of
the third October 24th right here on TSN as
Coffield right on flurry and another save for
the veteran tender Coffield again for saard
saard in front cross I pass score and they
finally break through Alex new hook little
bit of life with 225 to go it's 52 for the Wild
Well it certainly doesn't have an impact on the
direct hockey game but it has an impact on the
individuals making the plays Cole cof with a
very strong play from the top of the zone and
David card with a great look across to Alex
new hook and Coffield he'll zip it across mat
towards it at Suzuki weak one time drive and
gallager in front tied up one last chance
new hook through the crease it went in but
before I believe the Hornet sounded as new hook
nearly slipped another one by Mark Andre flurry